d'abord françois de rugy il va
s'installer il va ouvrir la séance et
ensuite il va inviter le président de la
république à venir puisque le règlement
du congrès est extrêmement précis
l'article 23 à l'heure fixée pour sa
déclaration le président de la
république être introduit dans
l'hémicycle sur ordre du président du
congrès lequel lui donne aussitôt la
parole et on voit bien j'allais dire que
le président de la république n'est pas
chez lui 1 à versailles au congrès du
parlement ce sont les parlementaires qui
sont chez lui et il ne peut pas prendre
la parole
si le président du congrès formellement
dans les agrégats de pardon ne la lui
donne pas on va attendre donc l'arrivée
du président du congrès cet après midi
françois de président de l'assemblée
nationale selon le protocole
le voilà
le moment est solennel à on le voit sur
ces images dj mouss de françois de rugy
qui vient d'être élu en remplacement de
claude bartolone président de
l'assemblée nationale c'est un beau
début de mandat pour un nouveau
président de l'assemblée nationale photo
dojo la semaine dernière les violations
bon et c'est sûrement très
impressionnant de parcourir cette
galerie entre la la la double haie de
gardes républicains comme ça il a
rappelé que c'était un hommage rendu au
parlement françois de rugy
cette convocation du congrès côté on
vient de dire depuis quasiment une heure
que ça nous paraissait logique que dans
la hiérarchie il de la vème république
dont il est logique que le président de
la république la vienne dire devant les
parlementaires
ce qu'il a dans la tête pour les
quelques années qui viennent il aurait
pu le faire autrement c'est vrai mais il
a choisi une dysphonie une procédure est
ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle en application
de l'article 18 alinéa 2 de la
constitution la déclaration du président
de la république
cette déclaration sera suivie d'un débat
j'invite les membres du congrès à
accueillir le président de la république
voix emmanuel macron qui arrive donc
après l'ouverture de la séance
d'ouverture prononcé on a dit par
françois de rugy
monsieur le président de la république
au nom du congrès du parlement je vous
souhaite la bienvenue avant de vous
donner la parole
je voudrais évoquer un exemple un
symbole une référence simone veil occupe
désormais une place particulière dans
notre mémoire nationale
survivante de la shoah elle a su puiser
dans les drames qui ont défiguré notre
continent et avilit l'humanité une force
qui a fait d'elle une actrice
déterminante de l'engagement européen de
la france
elle a joué au terme d'un combat
législatif concret difficile et
victorieux un rôle considérable pour
l'émancipation des femmes
elle a toujours agi pour la protection
des plus fragiles
la vie de simone veil témoigne plus que
tout autre du prix de la liberté de la
difficulté du combat pour l'égalité de
l'impérieuse nécessité de la fraternité
observons en sa mémoire une minute de
silence
je vous remercie
monsieur le président de la république
je vous donne la parole